[Musique]
ce mercredi 31 août une c a présenté une
étude sur les déclencheurs et la
persistance de la pauvreté à la réunion
lors d'une conférence de presse dans ses
locaux une étude rendue publique en
présence de tous les partenaires parmi
eux le conseil départemental
la direction de l'économie de l'emploi
du travail et de la solidarité ainsi que
la caisse d'allocations familiales alors
à la réunion 20 d'un adulte sur 100 sont
touchés par de la pauvreté de longue
durée c'est quatre fois plus que dans
l'hexagone toutefois chaque année à la
réunion il ya davantage de sortie de
pauvreté que de basculent dans la
pauvreté
l'emploi
le fait de trouver un emploi permet de
sortir de la pauvreté trois fois plus
souvent qu'en moyenne dans la population
réunionnaise perdre son emploi au
contraire
est un risque qu un risque de bascule
deux fois plus important qu'en moyens
dans la population les événements
familiaux peuvent entraîner des bascules
un peu plus importante que la moyenne
dans la pauvreté mais aussi des sorties
de pauvreté un peu plus importante par
exemple les unions entraîne un petit peu
plus de sortie de pauvreté que dans la
moyenne à la réunion al'inverse les
naissances ou les séparations cause un
peu plus de basculent dans la pauvreté
les éléments de réponses fournies par
l'institut de statistiques permettront
département de la réunion ainsi que les
acteurs sociaux de mieux cibler les
politiques publiques pour enrayer le
phénomène
nono action rentre dans le cadre de la
lutte de du grand plan de lutte contre
la pauvreté est le département qui est
chef de file de l'action sociale à la
réunion et bien évidemment partenaire
incontournable dans cette lutte contre
la pauvreté il est important pour nous
que l'emploi parce que l'étude le
démontre que l'emploi est un facteur de
sortie de pauvreté donc il est important
que l'ensemble des politiques en faveur
de l'emploi soient renforcés au niveau
local et notamment on nous sommes
intervenus auprès du gouvernement pour
que l'aide aux contrats d'apprentissage
led qui accompagne donc ces dispositifs
d'apprentissage soit maintenue à la
réunion comme c'est ce fut le cas entre
2020 et 2022 sur la période 2015 à 2018
il ressort que 20% des adultes à la
réunion sont pauvres durablement soit
quatre fois plus qu'en france
métropolitaine
[Musique]